we know that the vaccine is safe
and helps make you safe it gives you
this protection
and dr mary ramsey is with us because
she's going to set out details of
a publication that public health england
have just released
with more evidence of the impact of the
vaccine to show what this protection is
like
and that shows that after a single dose
of the vaccine
either vaccine protection against
covid19 is around
60 percent that's protection against
getting it
protection against hospitalization is
around 80
and protection against death is around
and one of the other interesting facts
that is really important is that the
vaccine offers protection to you but it
also protect
offers protection to those around you
and the data show
that if you live with someone who's been
vaccinated you have a 30 percent lower
risk
of catching covid19 yourself
this is the first data that directly
measures the impact of the vaccine on
reducing transmission
and it shows that the vaccines are
saving lives
both vaccines being rolled out in the uk
are not just safe but they make you safe
they're saving lives
and protecting people and because we're
rolling out
so fast and because we've protected so
many people so quickly
we're now able to extend the offer of a
vaccination to yet
more people all people age 50 and above
are from today invited to come forward
and get a jam
the nhs will contact you and today we're
sending over
two million texts and letters and
invitations
to get vaccinated anyone aged 50 and
over
can now sign up on the nhs.uk website
or call 119. we're on track to offer a
first dose to everyone in priority
groups 1 to 9 by the 15th of april
while we deliver on that commitment we
also want to ensure
that this offer reaches everyone in
groups one to nine
so at the same time as
opening up offers of vaccinations to all
those who are 50 or above
we're going to do whatever it takes to
reach all those
in the most vulnerable groups who
haven't come forward yet
before we move on to the next cohort
which is people in their 40s
so my message to our huge team of
vaccinators
is let's keep getting the numbers
through the doors
but it's absolutely critical that we
reach out and we loop back
and we invite in yet again all those who
are in vulnerable groups
who haven't yet been vaccinated i want
to get those percentages of the
people in vulnerable groups the
percentages who've been vaccinated i
want to get them
right up reaching every last vulnerable
person
and it is worth that extra effort
and we'll do that before we move on to
people in their 40s
now i'm 42 and i'm as eager as anyone
to get the jam but before we forge ahead
i want us to be
confident that we've done everything we
can to protect those
most in need of protection and we will
do all we can
and do everything necessary to secure
the supplies
that are contractually committed to
protecting people
in this country so we're moving in the
right direction
thanks to everybody following the rules
that are keeping us safe now and thanks
to everybody coming forward
to get a jab that will keep us safe
for the future now is not the time to
waver
we're on the road to recovery the
vaccine is our way out
we are on track so let's stick with it
follow the rules
and when you get the call get the jab